[Music]
Kevin from the chess website calm today
we're gonna be looking at the Halloween
gambit and the Halloween game it derives
from the four Knights game which is not
too common but you may come across it a
few times
I wouldn't recommend this too often
especially during competitive play as
white does give up a lot of material and
if black plays correctly can have a very
good game but if you're just playing for
fun or playing recreational chess and
you do come across this it's definitely
something that you can have in your bag
of tricks is if black doesn't play
correctly he can he can be in a lot of
trouble so we're gonna go ahead and go
over the the main lines and actually
take a look at a game that was played in
top level not too long ago and kind of
look how top level people approach the
game so it starts out you can come about
the four night opening a few ways but
we'll just go over one common way and
that's Pawnee for Pawnee five night
development to f3 black responds night
development c6 night development night
development and here you see the move
Knight captures 'if I've and this does a
few things one obviously we are
sacrificing our night and basically we
are saying that we want to control the
center obviously after black takes we
are going to push our pond up nights
this nights going to have to move and so
we right away have Center control with
our ponds we are down two points in
material but what we hope to gain from
that is tempo in an advantage in
attacking lines so from here black can
do to basically move to places he can
move back to c6 or g6 will look at both
of those real quick if it moves back to
c6 we're just going to continue to push
up our pawns and put pressure black can
move back to the space we left behind
always keep in mind where your opponent
is leaving space and now we're actually
going to push up our F pawn putting more
pressure black is cannot retreat back to
this six c6 square so he's going to
retreat back to this g6 square and we're
now gonna put pressure on this f6 Knight
and he's not going to retreat and as you
can see we have a lot of pawns here we
are a little overextended maybe more
than I would like to be but black
doesn't have many pieces out he has one
night developed all the way from b6 here
and that's the only piece that he's
moved so we do definitely have a spatial
advantage on him and play from here will
continue we would move up if black takes
we now have a strong pawn on this d6
square our queen is defending it
eventually we're going to want to bring
our knight to b5 and then to c7 forking
the rook
black cannot take this because we have
our Queen here and this pawn is
protected by our Bishop so he cannot
take that right away so eventually we're
gonna want a Castle queenside obviously
our King side is pretty beaten up right
now and so eventually we're probably
going to Castle queenside bring our rook
into the attack again in this offense
you're you're gonna want to attack a lot
since that's what we sacrificed a piece
for if you're gonna play a defensive man
I want to play this opening anytime we
can come in bring our queen attack the
the black King on e8
capture that with our pawn so just
something to keep in mind when you are
playing another move that black can make
we did look at if he went to c6 another
movie can make is simply g6 we're from
here we're going to continue to push up
and if as you see here we don't have our
F pawn in the mix but we're gonna go
ahead and bring in our Bishop into the
action attacking this f7 squared which
is a huge weakness for black eventually
we like to get our Queen in here
obviously now we can Castle kingside our
King sides a little stronger
we have great center control black can
always try to block us by getting his
Queen involved basically sacrificing a
piece to gain back some some momentum
here we can go ahead and take that our
knight is protecting and then when he
tries to challenge we can go ahead and
fall back still attacking this f7 square
we're down one point material but we do
have huge protection in the middle so
definitely good attacking lines here now
it was discovered that if black plays
correctly
that he can't have a very good game and
it looks something like this after white
pushes to d5 instead of moving the
knight here black can actually come down
with a great move Bishop to b4 Black's
gonna go ahead and give away this piece
and we'll see what happens here in the
the best defense once this is taken
blacks going to take this pawn and this
Knight is pinned so he cannot take this
Knight and so there's a pin on the King
eventually this piece is going to be
lost so white can try to attack both
pieces and put pressure black can come
in and protect this Knight
obviously if black tries to take this
Bishop we have a discovered attack on
the King where we can go we can take a
piece and attack the the King here so
from here you may see white try to take
this free pawn on g7
and now we can unleash many discovered
checks here this is a discover check
with the Queen if white tries to block
here we have another discovered check
from the bishop once white tries to stop
that we can now bring our rook here
obviously white was going to take that
very soon so as you can see we have a
lot of attacks coming we can't obviously
take this bishop so definitely a good
defense for black here so now we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
famous game played with this opening and
look how
top players play so starts out as normal
with the four Knights defense offered up
the gambit accepted and white pushes
forward black falls back we push forward
and kind of the same lines that we said
before white pushes forward with the f4
pawn and we start to chase it looks like
and then we continue to push our pawns
this is a very aggressive pawn structure
as you can see after black takes we have
our pawn nicely located on the d6 square
blacks going to try to free up his queen
attacking he's now has two attackers on
this d6 square and is eyeing two
attackers on this f4 square we're going
to totally disregard that and continue
with our plan we're trying to come to
the c7 square and fork the rook Black's
gonna go ahead and move his rook and
we're gonna go ahead and bring another
attacker on this a7 file and develop our
bishop here eventually we want to move
our Queen and Castle queenside to add
another attacker with the rook onto the
King likes gonna go ahead and stop our
attack with the bishop here and we're
gonna go ahead and move our Queen now we
have a discovered to check when we want
to on the King if we move our Bishop so
after the King moves which he saw this
discovered looks like it we're gonna go
ahead and castle here looks like and
then black is going to try to lock up
this efile that we had bearing down on
them we're gonna go ahead and put some
pressure sacrificed another piece again
more sacrificing a lot of pieces to gain
momentum
looks like blacks gonna take and we're
gonna go ahead and Center right here on
the see Foursquare eyeing down the c7
square which be a brutal attack and we
have a lot of pieces attacking black
right now we can bring our rook in we've
already castled and black doesn't have a
lot develop so we're gonna see what he
does he's gonna move to a more
centralized location
we're gonna go ahead and check the king
and he's gonna have to move to the e8
square we're gonna go ahead and move our
bishop to safety and attack the Queen
and he's gonna move it and check us so
we're gonna go ahead and bring the King
back blacks gonna go ahead and put his
knight or excuse me his rook in safety
it looks like we were attacking and
we're gonna go ahead and put the King in
check and after they block we're gonna
go ahead and try to get this Queen out
of the way and after the Queen moves
here it looks like we're going to
sacrifice a piece and you'll see why
here in a minute he's attacking our rook
so we need to free up this defender and
we want to get this Queen out of the way
for this brutal attack that we have
coming up and after he takes it's just
devastating from here this pawn looks
like this GM took and after black
captures obviously can't capture with
the King because of the rook we have a
devastating check and after the King
moves he was able to come in with a
queen for checkmate
so definitely devastating attack once
black was unable to defend correctly so
you definitely can't have a very good
game if played correctly so keep this in
mind hopefully you enjoyed this video
please subscribe there's a lot more
videos coming out check out the website
chess website calm a lot of good stuff
on there and see you guys next video